now our next guest has an interesting
perspective on the hunter Biden news
both as a former U.S attorney
Prosecuting these types of cases and as
the former director of the National
Intelligence Agency that dealt with the
FBI and its handling of the hunter
laptop back in 2020 joining me now John
Ratcliffe former Trump Director of
National Intel John
now you've heard all of this in all when
all the details of the hunter Biden
laptop came out back in 2020
everything on it was quickly labeled as
disinformation get everybody off the
scent but this whistleblower reveals
something that the FBI and the IRS knew
before the laptop went public
what can you tell us
yeah Laura I'll just say first of all I
I watched The Whistleblower uh today uh
credible competent and everything that
he said uh added up made sense
consistent with Department of Justice
and uh and U.S attorney manual uh
policies whereas what America Ireland
said simply doesn't add up and you
mentioned the fact that was U.S attorney
so
um but two things really uh stood out
from the what the Whistleblower said
tonight in his uh interview one we could
stop speculating that this was a
sweetheart deal for um for Hunter Biden
he said it he said the most serious
felony charges were left on the table
and he pointed out that special agent
report that went to the prosecutors
including ausa Leslie wolf laid out all
of the elements for those felony charges
and she agreed that they were met and at
some point after that that got reversed
um by who and and when we don't know but
those are those are things that you know
uh we're going to need to drill down to
find out but the but really the most
compelling thing that he said Laura was
when he talked about the fact that this
WhatsApp message that reveals Hunter
Biden shaking down Chinese
officials associated with the Chinese
Communist party for millions of dollars
that WhatsApp message he talked about
the fact that they authenticated it
through Apple they obtained it through
Apple so think about that that uh when
they were seeking these search warrants
that you were just talking about uh
relating to trying to get documents
about these Financial transactions
involving China and Ukraine and and and
other places in Hunter Biden
um the the FBI agents along with IRS
agents were affirming that that
information was credible that they had
probable cause to seek that yet within
months of that we know that other FBI
agents were going to social media
platforms and saying if you hear
something about Hunter Biden Joe Biden
the big guy uh Financial transactions
involving China and other countries it's
likely Russian disinformation those two
things really can't be reconciled I mean
FBI director Ray really needs to
publicly address that contradiction
one of the things that also came out
tonight was that Jim Comer
um Congressman Comer noted that the new
information they have includes that
payments went to non-biden family
members presumably other friends or
Associates of the bidens with new bank
other bank accounts other llc's and
other shell companies so this was a web
of transfers accounts trying to hot
clearly trying to hide where this money
was coming from and then Biden never
really revealed the source of his income
in that crucial year just how much
income he got which leads everyone to
ask how did Biden get so rich Joe Biden
how did he get started we don't know and
that's why this that's why this IRS
whistleblower is is saying none of this
makes sense you talked about the
WhatsApp message that Hunter Biden
bragging that nobody's better than the
bidens at the business that the chairman
wants done and you have an IRS
investigative team saying what is that
business yeah what do you do you don't
have any products so what services are
you providing what do you do better for
officials in China and Ukraine and
Romania and and that's why I think
they're all so motivated and so
distraught by the fact that this has
been swept under the rug very clearly
for political reasons that need to be
drilled down on
and a scale of 1 to 10 10 being the most
concerned How concerned are you John
that Joe Biden is compromised in our
dealings with China because of these
business uh dealings of a son
well I've just I've run out of other
reasons than to to think that he's
compromised I mean what else it can't it
it you know it can't be that he's that
incompetent it it can't be that he
doesn't care at all about One
detentional Security
I mean one one to ten it's concerned are
you 15 okay well that's pretty concerned
all right John thank you for your
perspective good to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else